oh not that one we'll try them don't
suck that nigga's safety I am with what
they follow up Jamal we opposed it out
to the wall
wow what a week
hey what's going to do it you all here -
oh nice
I'll help your belt will bear you
through the wall follow up hold the leg
round right get the counter headnotes
gone okay by the bird all the trade
fairs yeah that looks like this right
now my god it is for pants before but I
said raise your sod to give what all you
will get it go for looks with the
trooper roll okay
[Applause]
[Music]
other thing
I met with a nice students Oh
[Music]
you know every delay they're able to
maximize efficiency so here we go that
should end it here we go Oh Big O the
backswing blow big damage here one more
mix up oh this should be in oh my god
what a comeback there from Sophie no
luck on the boy
no because okay jump over all God just
like that scene is burning it around
Toby's not done you're going to test me
already cats are present downstairs he's
got rays available as well this is too
hard
raise your water call ball they're gonna
kill it's going to scale like crazy but
it might oh my god what a combo that's
going to be the highlight of all the
cloud going crazy
goodbye